there are many challenges Rangers face  poachers Rupert Rangers as obstacles  they couldn't do anything to make sure  that they get what they want they can  kill the Rangers and go to disco as well  when Portia threw an ax and it hurt me  the animals that the Ranger try protect  at times they also kill them this  happens especially when a poacher  injures the animal and the animal does  not differentiate between this Ranger  and their poacher  I lost a very good friend of mine who  was killed by a buffalo that was injured  the love for the work it's like a gift  you cannot work without any challenges  we still work even when we lose our  friends